she lived in new zealand
the birthplace of our for 15
years so please everyone welcome
gwen to the stage hi can you see me
jared
now i can oh perfect okay so hi
i'm uh gwen sturdivant i'm a postdoc at
a laboratory for innovation science at
harvard business school
and i'm so excited to have you here at
my talk and to
listen to all the other talks of this
conference what a great thing and thank
you jared and everyone else for
putting this together i know how much
work
it involves so let's get started and
we're going to talk about
faster coding or vectorizing
computations in r i did a little bit of
a talk about this at user 2020
and i'm not going to go through all the
details but basically i had a sample i
was
going to use a bootstrap to estimate the
population mean
and so i wrote some tidy burst coding
and it was taking forever
to run so what i decided to do you know
was i thought well i'll just
you know write some vectorized coding
i'll see if it runs a little bit quicker
and in fact it did it ran much quicker
so um here you can see how much quicker
in fact it ran so this is the tidy
coating it took
you know a lot longer sometimes about
nine ten times longer
and so i thought oh my goodness i didn't
realize that i was really surprised
that the tidy coding took so much longer
and i was
you know thinking off you know
vectorizing is a really good thing and
of course we'll talk a little bit more
about what vectorizing is but i want to
get back to the slide just a little bit
because i i think that there's an
important point about
some of the really basic differences in
tidy verse coding
and in um vectorized coding or
you know some people um it's it's
basically written in base r
so um if you look at this vectorized
coding
or let me just start with the tidy verse
because i think probably more people are
familiar with this so
tidy verse coding you read from top to
bottom right so we have this
we take the sample or you know i change
it to a data frame i take the sample
i pull the splits and then i take
columns so it's kind of you know you
read it like you read english
whereas vectorized coding or um
which you know is a base art first you
take the sample
so it's kind of you know it grows from
out to in
you take the sample and then i'm
replicating the sample n
times and then i take the column means
so
that is this is much more familiar
in you know in algebra in algebra when
we
come you know when we do a composition
of functions we go from out to in
and it gets bigger right you know it
gets
it goes like that so i just wanted to
point that out briefly here
at this slide and because we're going to
see it again
okay so when to vectorize now i really
like vectorizing functions that's kind
of
you know one of the things that i think
about first is how we're going to get
the code
to run fast but um you know don't be
like me
don't spend forever don't spend forever
uh vectorizing your
your coding and this is just a a simple
thing it says
if you do it five times a day and it
takes one second
over five years you're gonna save two
hours so you know
keep that in mind keep that in mind when
you um
when you are thinking about vectorizing
functions and
how how you want to work on it so um
right and what i'm going to talk about
today um this is a
um a tweet from elon musk where he was a
little grumpy he
he had um he took four covid rapid
antigen tests
and on one day two came out negative and
two came out positive and so what
happened in
in with that test is that that copic
test
trades um speed for accuracy
right so it's quick but it's it's not as
accurate and there's other things that
aren't accurate as well for example
blood pressure
your blood pressure measurement it
varies all the time um your cholesterol
levels and also
um what's the third one um
cholesterol oh it's fasting fasting
blood glucose which is
um used to diagnose um diabetes
so these things vary a lot and so
there's a lot of noisy measurements just
you know in in inherent biological data
and so i'm gonna
put uh some you know a complicated
equation on the site
say for example that we only have a
really noisy measurement
um what we want what we will do and we
want to study time to event
will you know which is survival analysis
will have this really horrible
discrete survival analysis uh formula
here
and then we'll have this uh we could
have this gamma
i and delta i ti which are
you know to take into account
sensitivity and specificity right so
this
this is a the specificity measurement
this is a
sensitivity measurement and um you know
why we would be closing the derivative
coding the derivative i mean
i guess the parameter that we're
probably interested in is beta is is the
is the treatment better than the
controls you know which arm does better
um right what was i saying oh yes and
you might want to vectorize
you might want to code the derivative
because it it can help some
things to run a little bit faster so um
right that's really icky it's really
really a horrible equation
and so the first thing that that i'm
going to tell you to do when you code
something like that
in our is to simplify it as much as you
possibly can
um and so if we look at this coding we
can see
that there is a number of um
you know repetitions we have this
1 plus e to the gamma naught j
to the negative um e to the
e x um sorry x transpose the x i
transpose beta
okay so we see that repeated a number of
times and so if i wanted to simplify
this function i could make this
substitution
and if you look carefully you'll see
that oh look this is 1 minus
this we call this the hazard risk
function right here so it's 1 minus that
so
right so if i wanted to simplify this
function even further what i could do
is make it like this so it's much easier
to deal with
okay so now we've kind of simplified it
now the next
step that i recommend doing and you must
do if you're ever going to code
something horrible and r
is to get a lot of clarity on what's
what's happening in that function
right so exactly what's happening so
let's look at this again
and let's take an example you know t so
so in this case
we have ti but we also have um ti
observed there's two different values
and the reason for that is because it's
there's a lot of noise there's miss
measurement so
let's just look at this first part
because that's the simple part and i
have this
j goes from it's a product this
um capital pi means product and so this
j goes from one to five
so i have the hazard rarest function
evaluated at
um x i for person i
uh uh gamma naught j
beta right and so the only thing that
changes is is the j
so i'm gonna have this function
evaluated at gamma naught one
and then a two i'm gonna multiply them
all together right so this is what i
have
in that first part not very pretty you
know
not very pretty you can see why they did
this but um
but it's there so let's look at this one
here
this next part so this next part's a bit
a little bit icky
um and um so let's just take
one value of k so if k is one then this
whole thing
j will go from one to zero this goes
away and i'm just left with
um the complement of the hazard risk
function evaluated at
gamma naught 1 times delta i
1 right so that's all i have
now let's go back and um if i do this at
2
what happens well i end up with uh
j goes from one to one so i'll have the
hazard risk function evaluated at gamma
naught one
times the complement of the hazard risk
fraction of that evaluated at
because k is two now at gamma naught two
times delta
so you can see the pattern right so i'm
i just add this
and then if it's three i'm gonna have uh
this evaluated at gamma naught two and i
just wanna apologize for going through a
lot of ugly math but i
i think the the coding is you know it's
really important
for you to understand this little bit of
coding even though it's not the
derivative
so that you can understand um the rest
how i'm
vectorizing it so here i have three
gamma naught one
and gamma naught two and then i multiply
by the complement and about
you know and and multiply by uh capital
delta i three
and so on right so that's that's what
happens
okay so before i'm gonna
i i go into vectorizing this whole thing
i want to talk a little bit about these
much
kind of simpler functions this capital
gamma i
and these delta delta i you know k or
whatever
so oh excuse me before i do that let's
talk about the derivative of this
function
i i forgot about this so let's um let's
look here
so i'm this is not a derivative taking
class i'm not going to go through the
whole
derivation of this but i do want to talk
a little bit about if i'm going to take
the derivative of this
thing with respect to one of these gamma
knots
uh whatever l that um
everything else is kept constant right
so that's the way
that we do this this is the product of
all of these ones that don't include l
and then i have the derivative um with
respect to gamma naught l
of this hazard risk function i just
multiply it at the end okay
so now i'm going to talk about what i
talked about earlier is
is um uh doing the
coding this and these things because i
think that's
um that's a good so a a good place to
start
so in in terms of vectorizing so
indexing is something that we talk about
in
r and you know for loops is one way to
do it there's other ways to do it
i'm gonna introduce you to a new way to
index
um or perhaps you've seen it before i
don't know um but i'm gonna introduce
you to a new another way to index an
r so we have this equation here so this
is the same equation that we saw uh you
know on the slide
an earlier slide and what i'm going to
talk about is how
to find this so what i want to do is i
mult want to multiply
uh let's just see i have i have an
example here
i want to multiply these vi's so if i
have
um these t t observed or
ti observed it will is two
then i'm gonna be multiplying just this
number here
right so if i'm if i'm looking at that i
just want to multiply these which means
you know if i'm going to multiply
perhaps i want to multiply across and
and that's a good way to do it the rest
of these need to be one right
so let's see i have this one is five and
i'm just going to talk about this so i
go from
one to four so that means i'm going to
multiply all of these
and then this one which is one will be
one and
then if this is one then this goes from
one to zero so it goes away it becomes
one
and so then all of these will need to be
one right
so how can we think about doing that in
a way that's really quick
and really fast so let's look here so
here's my tea observed
my ti it's oh excuse me oh
good i think it went right back to where
i was sometimes i touch my mouth and it
goes through the slides so anyway
if if if we're going through uh ti eb's
ti observed is two then i have
i want to everything all of these in
lots of feet
uh are greater than so let's let me see
so i just want to multiply this one i
said that before all of these need to be
one
right and so i can use this lots of i to
index
and say any of these lots of fees
that are bigger you know that have where
where this where this value is bigger
than or equal to
uh where the index is bigger than or
equal to the to the t
i observed i want them to be one right
so i just replace
so for example this one you know in fact
this case it is one
right but for this one here all of these
that are bigger i use this lots of i to
index off of it
and i want to change all of these to one
so in other words what i'm doing
is i'm gonna make it look like this
right so i have my point eight here
all of these are one this one is also
two so i have a 0.8
and um so how can i do this well it's so
it's really simple it's one line of
coding and here it is here
right so i have lots of fee i have lots
of i
i say whatever of these lots of i's are
greater than or equal to t
0 change them to 1 and then i just do
this
apply and i find this product and i've
found this part which is the most
difficult part
and then this one i can just index off
of uh use the t
the t i observe right so so d i is this
is survival analysis
um so d i observed is either zero or one
either event
an event occurs or it does not occur and
so one of these will go away
and i'll be left with uh the last value
of fee
and then i've i've done you know
the whole thing i've done that whole
thing so when you look at this coding
you might want to do like
15 for loops but you don't need to
please don't
just keep it simple okay um and this is
part of what i really enjoy about ours
thinking about ways to code where
where you know things can be vectorized
and they can run quicker and they can be
optimized
okay so let's talk a little bit about
this other one which
is delta delta i t i observed so
here i have the ti observed i think this
is pretty clear how to do
how to do this one because i just went
over it in the last slide it's the exact
same case
and then let's talk about this one here
so here i have this one minus theta j
and i have t i and i have ti observed
okay so let's just look at this so for
this first one
the ti and the t oh excuse me
i just did something there we go the ti
and the ti observed
are um are the same so that means that
i um let's see what does it mean exactly
yes so i'll i'll just be multiplying
these and this whole thing was going to
go away
right because it's going to be from
three to two doesn't make any sense
and then an event isn't observed so
let's look at this one
so here i'm going to have this is a
little bit more interesting
i have t i is three and then i have
t observed as five and an event occurs
at the fifth time point
so here um here i have i'll multiply
this
times uh i'll multiply this
twice right i'll multiply this two times
i'll multiply excuse me um
um phi phi one times v2
and then i'll i want one minus theta
right so i have v1 times v2 and then i
want one minus for these two so this is
from
three three two four
so i'm going to have point zero five and
point
zero two five right i'll multiply those
and then this one i'm just going to tag
on at the end like i did before
okay so this is a little bit different
but i'm going to try and make this
um this matrix here and what you see is
i have these lots of one minus thetas
and then what i do is i replace some of
these with
um uh so all of these need to be
replaced with one for the first one
because
they the they happen at the same time
and this one i have i'm going to replace
these two
with one and those two with one right so
this is what i want to get at
right and the rest it's very similar you
can see
it's just the pattern that i continue
here
so this is the coding that does that we
just have lots of one minus theta
and i take the ones that are less than t
i and i turn them to one and the ones
that are greater than t
zero greater than or equal to zero and i
turn those to one and then i can just
find the product
and of course part one i haven't
included here okay
let's keep going so one thing i want to
talk to you briefly about
then that you need to think carefully
about when you do
this kind of vectorizing coding is the
dimensions and so i'm going to introduce
you to this
uh this function the outer function it
takes two vectors and it applies
a function to all the different values
of that function
okay so um right
and then we're going to talk a little
bit about going from inside to out again
i talked about that earlier
and i told you you'd see it again and
here it is so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
first address this
this function here because i think uh
you know it's the right place to go and
of course we're going to go from inside
to out
and that is here right so i'm starting
with this
and i also have to put the derivative in
so i can set this seed i have some gamma
some beta and i make this x beta
you know very simple um i have the risk
which is
i and i round it that's one of the
things i like about tidy versus you
don't have to round it doesn't give you
15 different
different decimal places like base r
does and then here i take
this and i find all of these hr's so all
of the hr's are right there
right here right now what am i going to
do with those
hr's right um
i'm going to multiply them right so here
i found
this the exact same coding you've seen
before this is the derivative here
and then i want to apply
the product to this and i take off which
gamma
right and i multiply by the derivative
so you might look at this and think oh
my goodness i'm going to have to write
how am i gonna do that how i'm gonna
code it but you can see that this is
you know like five tens lines five ten
lines of coding
okay so let's keep going
we're almost there i don't know how many
people had halloween uh candy shoots
in their neighborhood but we had a
halloween candy shoot in my
in my neighborhood and i i thought it
was a a very good uh analogy to a
function
so um anyway right so let's keep going
so what i have here is this oh oh my
goodness i tell you
what i have here is this and i'm oh my
goodness let me just go back
oof and i have this qualcomm prod so i'm
going to use
this to take the product of all of these
and i'm
i don't really have the time to to talk
about uh
all of this in in a lot of detail but um
i'm just gonna show you the coding and
um and i think i'm gonna be done
but but what i do want to show you about
this for loop is that it goes
from it goes through the number of
columns right so i'm going through the
the smallest dimension that i possibly
can because of course
you know the data that i showed you only
had four or five people involved in the
trial but
most likely is going to have many more
okay
so what i do here is i have this i have
the
derivative and then i make this the c
c buying thing here so i do this column
this
uh cumulative product of of the columns
that's this
and i take off the gamma and i take off
uh the one that i'm taking the
derivative with and i take off the last
one
and then i multiply by the derivative
and then
one minus beta right so that's this one
one minus beta here
and um i replace those with
uh the ones that i'm not interested in
right from l l plus one to t i
0 right which is which gamma l plus 1
and ti 0 becomes 0 and then i just add
them all together
okay so i think i'm done
and the take home message is to really
avoid for loops
and to try to do calculations in big
huge chunks
right so that's all i have to say
thank you much very much for coming to
my talk and i am going to stop
sharing now great thank you very much
for your talk
that was excellent i always love a good
vectorization it really can make
dramatic differences in your code
and makes it more or like so that's
always pretty awesome
okay